Kartentwicklung, Kart-Check-Ile,
die ganzen Datenbildungen oder keine.
Aber wir müssen in der Prüfung die Personalitäten noch mal fragen.
Das ist aber die Prüfungssituation, das war alles.
Genau, genau.
Und wir können sagen auch, ja, die haben recht, aber ich muss noch mal fragen,
um sicher zu sein, vielleicht können wir sagen.
Aber es ist ihr gutes Recht, dann sie entscheidet,
ob sie das nicht möchte.
Dann ist das so in Ordnung.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Jetzt noch mal, wenn jemand bewusstlos ist,
man muss reanimieren, dann musst du helfen.
Wenn du das nicht machst, dann ist das eine Unterlass in der Hilfeleistung.
Das ist eine sehr akuten, lebensbedrohliche Zustand,
musst du helfen.
Da ist aber meistens der Patient sowieso bewusstlos
und kann nicht reagieren, das ist eine andere Situation.
Imsalatımız Kartenladen, ne?
Was sind?
Ja, gerne an der Formade.
Der Formulat ist der Frau Müller,
lehnt die Behandlung durch mich ab.
Ich bin der Mann.
Das hat die Frau auf 220° vídeo boiliert.
Sie necessitiert die Frau.
Sie ist selbst als eine Reaktion sein Papa,
das eine reaktion ist.
Sie ist selbst als eine Reaktion.
Was ist sein Gender,
die du sie
Du kannst natürlich auch.
Das ist das Problem.
Ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Ja, ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Wenn man von einer Art von einer Art von einer Art,
dann wird man stresslos.
Man ist ein Mensch.
Ja, der Herr Tejbe ist sehr schön.
Er ist immer gut.